Sao quan mềm một tháng huyên năm 2018, trong nước tự hiện diện vụ uống phó mưa báo,
đồng chi phàn văn thành, sinh năm 2018, chú tại sống Sơn Hà Một,
Sát Hình công, Tình Tháng Vên, Tổ Chủ Tổ bảo Vệ Anh,
chất tự sống Sơn Hà Một, cùng anh quyến và giữ phản giữ phản phân đoán phát hiện bà chó nhỏ
có giữ rối nước tại đoạn đường dân sinh đi qua kánh đồng.
Đồng chi thình đã bơi và đưa được hai chấu vào khu vực an quan,
sau đó, tức tục môi trở lại địa kiểu và đưa được chấu thứ 3 vào đến gần bộ thì bị đối xức và bị quân thơ giống nước.
Anh muyến và giúp, miến và đoán đã kiệt thời hỗ trợ đưa chấu bế và đưa ăn quan,
nhưng ra nước lớn nề khổ cứu được đồng chi thình.
Đến chính giờ quân hại, lượng lượng chức năng đã tìm thấy thi thể của đồng chi thình.
Ngay trong hại, đoàn công tác của công an tình tháng huyên gió đại táa trọng chung,
phó rám đốc công an tình giữ đồng, cũng đến đạo các đường viện nghi vụ đã đến tham hoàn,
đồng viên chia sẻ mất mất mất với gia đình đồng chi thình.
Để táa cho chung bài tỏ sự trên trọng chức tình thình gió cả,
hế lòng viên giên phục vụ của anh.
Thay mặt lãnh đạo công an tình, để táa cho chung người lời chia buồn sâu sắc,
bài tỏ sự trên trọng hành động gió cả,
quyên mình viên giên của đồng chi phăn văn thành,
đồng thời Ấn cần tham hoàn, chia sẻ, đồng viên thân nhân vừa qua đối đau mất mất mất.
Ví nhìn hành động gió cả, quyên mình kiểu người,
chú tịch i bán nhân rất tình tháng viên đã chuy tạo măn khán cho đồng chi phăn văn thành,
đồng thời Ấn cần thằng măn khán cho anh viên và giữ vãnh viên vành đỏng.